das ist ein historischer Tag für den
Haushaltsgesetzgeber und auch für die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler in
Deutschland die Entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsrichts vom heutigen Tag
wird langfristige Wirkungen haben auf
die Haushaltsplanung und auf die
haushaltsgestaltung aller
Bundesregierungen es ist vor allem eine
Entscheidung die die Rechte des
Deutschen Bundestages stärkt und der
Bundesregierung werden durch diese
Entscheidung jetzt klare Grenzen auf
zeigt bei der Aufnahme von immer neuen
Schulden zur Erinnerung in unserer Klage
ging es darum dass die Bundesregierung
einen nachträglichen Haushalt
aufgestellt hat mit nachträglichen
Schulden in Höhe von 60 Milliarden Euro
die sie aus dem ursprünglichen
coronafond umgewidmet hat in einen Klima
und
transformationsfond wir haben diese
Buchungsregeln und dieses rumtricksen
der Bundesregierung in Karlsruhe
überprüfen lassen
die Bundesregierung hat ja auch den
Begriff des Sondervermögens verändert
wir hatten früher in Deutschland immer
wieder mal Sondervermögen die Waren auch
tatsächlich mit Geld gefüllt da war Geld
in den Vermögen die Sondervermögen
dieser Bundesregierung sind all samt nur
Schulden gewesen auch
diese Möglichkeiten jetzt der
unbenennung von Schulden in Vermögen hat
mit dem heutigen Tag ein Ende gefunden
das höchste deutsche Gericht hat unserer
Klage in allen Punkten stattgegeben das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat nicht nur
den Nachtragshaushalt für das Jahr
2021 für verfassungswiedrig erklärt
sondern auch für nichtig das ist
insofern von großer Bedeutung weil es
schon einmal in früheren Jahren
bundeshaushalte oder Teile von
bundeshaushalten gegeben die gegeben hat
die für verfassungswiedrig erklärt
worden sind und dann ist dem Gesetzgeber
ein gewisser Spielraum gegeben worden
wie man denn mit einem Verfassungs
wiedrigen Haushalt umgeht und ihn dann
auch heilt das ist mit dieser
Entscheidung nicht möglich nichtig heißt
von Anfang an unwirksam und von Anfang
an unwirksam heißt dass im Rahmen dieser
60 Milliarden Euro die die
Bundesregierung zum Teil ja schon
ausgegeben hat oder über die sie
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen eingegeben
hat rückgängig gemacht werden muss
müssen diese Urteil hat damit sehr
weitreichende Folgen karlsruh hat zum
ersten Mal auch eine Entscheidung über
die Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz
getroffen bis jetzt hat es dazu keine
rechtprechung gegeben vollgichtig hat
der Bundesfinanzminister auch eine
Sperre eine ausgabensperre verhängt über
alle Ausgaben die aus diesem
Nachtragshaushalt finanziert werden
sollten wir gehen davon aus ich gehe
davon aus dass damit auch der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond der WSF
betroffen ist denn das ist eine ähnliche
wenn auch nicht genau gleiche aber eine
ähnliche Konstruktion womit Schulden die
für einen bestimmten Zweck Abweichen von
der Schuldenbremse des Grundgesetzes
aufgenommen wurden über mehrere Jahre
infolge Geld ausgegeben werden soll das
nicht durch den regulären Bundeshaushalt
finanziert wird wir werden das
überprüfen lassen wir werden dazu ein
Rechtsgutachten Anst anfertigen lassen
ob denn möglicherweise diese heutige
Rechtssprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes auch
übertragbar ist auf den Wirtschafts und
stabilisierungsfond diese Entscheidung
entzieht der gesamten Finanz- und
Haushaltsplanung der Bundesregierung die
Grundlage insbesondere der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ist betroffen
von seinen Projekten die er jetzt auf
diesem Weg nicht mehr finanzieren kann
die Regierung wird andere Formen der
Finanzierung suchen müssen und zwar in
im Rahmen eines regulären Haushaltes der
dann auch auch im jahresrhthmus mit
Einnahmen und Ausgaben finanziert werden
muss noch einmal das ist das Ende aller
Schattenhaushalte jedenfalls derer die
Schulden finanziert sind
wir können jetzt die Terminologie dieser
Koalition auch
weiterhin vergessen die da immer lautete
es gibt einen Kernhaushalt und es gibt
ergänzungshaushalte das gibt es jetzt
alles nicht mehr es gibt jetzt einen
Bundeshaushalt in dem alle Einnahmen und
Ausgaben nach dem jährlichkeitsprinzip
zu verbuchen sind und das wird die
Bundesregierung vor große
Herausforderungen stellen ich will die
Bundesregierung auffordern erstens die
Haushaltsberatungen die jetzt morgen
fortgesetzt werden sollen zu
unterbrechen damit Sie die Gelegenheit
hat für das Jahr 2024 einen
verfassungskonformen Haushalt vorzulegen
ich will der Bundesregierung zweitens
sagen machen Sie bitte nicht den Versuch
das an anderer Stelle zu wiederholen was
sie hier mit dem verfassungswiedrigen
und nichtigen äh Fond gemacht haben und
drittens äh sie werden von uns keine
Zustimmung bekommen wenn sie denn
ernsthafterweise jetzt vorschlagen
sollten die Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes zu lockern dafür gibt es
keinerlei Rechtfertigung keine Grundlage
die Voraussetzungen nicht sind nicht
erfüllt die Bundesregierung muss jetzt
das erste Mal in ihrer Amtszeit etwas
tun was sie bis jetzt sorgfältig
vermieden hat sie muss mit dem Geld
auskommen das im Bundeshaushalt der
Bundes Republik Deutschland vereinnammt
wird herzlichen Dank sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren dieses Urteil ist eine
Klatsche mit Wums um nicht zu sagen mit
doppelwums für den Bundeskanzler und die
Ampel es ist jetzt amtlich dass die
Haushalts und Finanzpolitik der Ampel
unseriös verfassungswidrig und nichtig
ist es ist in der Tat ein historischer
Moment weil die Politik das politprinzip
der ampels Schulden machen als gäbe es
kein Morgen dem es unmissverständlich
ein Ende gesetzt worden das
Verfassungsgericht hat deutlich gemacht
dass eingegangene Verpflichtungen
anderweitig kompensiert werden müssen
dieser Satz des Verfassungsgerichts
schließt ein weiter so aus und deswegen
ist es umso
unverständlicher und auch
fahrlässig dass der Bundeskanzler gerade
im Deutschen
Bundestag darauf angesprochen angedeutet
hat dass die Ampel jetzt nicht darauf
reagieren werde und die bisherigen
Haushaltsberatungen so abgeschlossen
werden als gäbe es dieses Urteil nicht
ich halte das in der Tat für
fahrlässig und kann an der Stelle die
Ampel nur warnen jetzt nicht wieder
einen verfassungswidrigen Haushalt
aufzulegen oder zu glauben ein Aushebeln
der Schuldenbremse könnte dies heilen
wir werden dazu keine Zustimmung geben
wenn es einen erneuten Versuch gibt
einen verfassungswidrigen Haushalt zu
konstruieren werden wir auch wieder
dagegen klagen wir machen ein paar
Fragen und legen hier vorne los mit Frau
siet von T online
bitte würde gerne einmal nachfragen
angenommen die Situation
kärt sich nicht und die Ampel löst sich
auf süe die Union dann bereit für
alternative Regierung die eine große
Koalition oder ist das dann der Moment
für
Neuwahlen wir werden die Frage dann
beantworten wenn sie sich stellt heute
geht es zunächst einmal darum dass die
Regierung die im Amt ist sich so verhält
wie die Verfassung es verlangt und wie
das Bundesverfassungsgerichtes heute
entschieden hat
wir werden jetzt zunächst einmal die
Beratungen dieser Bundesregierung
begleiten und ich schließe mich dem an
was Alexander Dobrind gerade gesagt hat
wir werden wenn die Regierung den
Versuch machen sollte hier erneut die
Verfassung zu brechen erneut sofort nach
Karlsruhe gehen alles andere werden wir
dann beantworten wenn sich die Fragen
stellen erstmal hat sich der hausalt der
Ampel aufgelöst und was daraus jetzt für
die drei Parteien Volk das müssen die
entscheiden mein Eindruck ist dass die
Ampel vollkommen unvorbereitet getroffen
worden ist von dieser Entscheidung
anders ist es ja nicht zu erklären dass
man zwar heute ähm darlegt dass
der ähm dass dieses Geld nicht mehr zur
Verfügung steht dass die 60 Milliarden
sich in Rauch aufgelöst haben und der
KTF eine Haushaltssperre bekommt keine
neuen Entscheidungen drüber getroffen
werden können aber gleichzeitig der
Wirtschaftsminister erklärt dass seine
Projekte weiterlaufen sollen das geht
schlichtweg nicht zusammen und von daher
es gibt anscheinend erheblichsten
Beratungsbedarf innerhalb der Ampel wir
werden das nicht nur abwarten sondern
einfordern dass die Ampel dies auch dann
öffentlich formuliert und uns in Kentnis
setzt wie sie damit vor hat umzugehen
nächste Frage bitte Herr Rinke von Reus
ja Fragen einmal haben sie jetzt sehr
klar formuliert was nicht geht z auch
gesagt könen Sie bitte noch mal sagen
was für Optionen Ihrer Meinung nach die
Ampel diesem Haushalt also ist das nur
Einsparung oder gibt noch andereel und
zweitens der bundeskanz eben betont dass
es möglicherweise auch Auswirkung auf
die Länder Haushalte haben könnte sind
sie in ihrer Analyse auch dazu gekommen
dass möglicherweise auch die
Länder ja ich fange mit dem letzten an
das ist wahrscheinlich so wir müssen
jetzt mal abwarten bis die schriftlichen
Entscheidungsgründe vorliegen aber ich
gehe mal davon aus dass
diese Entscheidung auch weitreichende
Folgen hat für die Aufstellung der
Länderhaushalte und dass wir damit alle
im Bund in den Ländern vor die
Notwendigkeit gestellt sind jetzt wieder
so wie es früher unter Wolfgang Schäuble
möglich war mit dem Geld auszukommen
dass an Steuereinnahmen vereinnahmt wird
ausgeglichene Haushalte sind im übrigen
kein selbst Zweck sondern dienen auch
der Stabilisierung einer Volkswirtschaft
wir wissen ja nun auch aus der
langjährigen Geschichte von
Haushaltspolitik dass dann wenn die
Schulden hoch sind und die Defizite hoch
sind die Arbeitslosigkeit hoch ist und
die Wirtschaftsleistung niedrig also das
hat alles einen größeren
Zusammenhang wenn Sie es mal bei Licht
betrachten wir haben ja eine
zeitenwendeiskussion seit dem letzten
Jahr im Grunde genommen ist die
Zeitenwende erst mit der Entscheidung
des heutigen Tages Wirklichkeit geworden
ich habe den Bundeskanzler im letzten
Jahr erfolglos
aufgefordert diesen Krieg in der Ukraine
und die neuen
finanzierungsnotwendigkeiten im Hinblick
auf unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit zum
Anlass zu nehmen die Prioritäten auch im
Bundeshaushalt neu zu ordnen der
Bundeskanzler hat das nicht nur
abgelehnt er hat ja sogar wenige Wochen
nach seiner Regierungserklärung vom 27
Februar zugesagt alle Verabredungen des
Koalitionsvertrages einzuhalten und auch
zu finanzieren das geht nun spätestens
mit dem heutigen Tag endgültig nicht
mehr die Bundesregierung muss die
Prioritäten ihrer Ausgaben jetzt
wirklich grundlegend neu ordnen wenn Sie
sich dazu nicht in der Lage sieht dann
ist im Grunde genommen diese
Bundesregierung haushaltspolitisch
finanzpolitisch aber auch
verteidigungspolitisch und
wirtschaftspolitisch am Ende aber diese
Aufforderung die will ich heute noch
einmal wiederholen das hätte die die
Bundesregierung schon im letzten Jahr
tun müssen das hat sie aus politischen
Gründen abgelehnt spätestens seit heute
muss sie das aus verfassungsrechtlichen
Gründen tun und jetzt gibt es keine
Ausreden mehr wenn dem KTF die Mittel
entzogen sind durch dieses Urteil dann
muss die ampl als erstes mal beantworten
wie es mit diesen Projekten die durch
den KTF finanziert werden sollen jetzt
weitergeht und relativ abstrakt zu sagen
das betrifft auch die äh Länder das ist
jetzt noch keine Aussage über die
Projekte die da drinnen stehen also da
hat jetzt die Ampel doch eine Aufgabe
und daran zeigt sich doch auch schon
dass es kein Haushaltsverfahren geben
kann das so wie bisher weiter läuft weil
schlichtweg den Projekten die
Finanzierungsgrundlage entzogen worden
ist deswegen ist umso verwunderlicher
dass man hier jetzt am
Haushaltsverfahren offensichtlich
festhalten will das entzieht sich jeder
Logik ist fahrlässig und hat
wahrscheinlich eine hohe
Fehlerhaftigkeit ma noch eine Frage Herr
Decker vom RMD bitte Herr
März was bedeutet das denn jetzt ganz
praktisch das heißt wenn es nach ihnen
ginge dann würde die Bereinigungssitzung
ausfallen morgen dann würde die
Beschlussfassung des Haushaltes
ausfallen und die die Ampel müsste einen
neuen Haushalt vorlegen der dann
mutmaßlich zu Beginn des Jahres oder im
Frühjahr beschlossen würde also
teilweise schon nachträglich für das
neue Jahr
ist es das was sie wollen und die zweite
Frage wenn sie sagen das ist das Ende
aller
Schattenhaushalte das Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr ist ja so gesehen auch
ein
schattenhaus zugestimmt richtig warum
sind sie denn da sozusagen von der weil
die die Bedeutung des Themas über sind
sie davon aben oder na ja wir sindinge
wir sind ja wir sind ja bei der bei dem
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr sind wir ja
ein vernämlich zu der Entscheidung
gekommen eine
Grundgesetzänderung damit zu verbinden
das heißt die im Grunde genommen die
Ausnahme von der Ausnahme des
Grundgesetzes ins Grundgesetz
geschrieben das haben wir einfach
nämlich so gemacht das kann man machen
also das was da jetzt zum Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr im Grundgesetz steht ist eine
Ausnahme von der ansonsten geltenden
Schuldenregel des Grundgesetzes und
keine Ausnahme der Schuldenregeln
sondern es ist im Grundgesetz eine
zusätzliche Finanzierung für das
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr ich stehe dazu
dass das richtig war auch wenn die
Bundesregierung ja auch dieses
Sondervermögen jetzt über den Sommer
entschieden hat zweckentfremde zu
verwenden denn unsere Verabredung war
dass für das
Sondervermögen nur langfristige
finanzierungsaufgaben Investitionen in
große Rüstungsvorhaben der Bundeswehr
finanziert werden jetzt finanzieren sie
aus dem Sondervermögen den laufenden
Betrieb der Bundeswehr das war nicht
unsere Verabredung aber das ist eine
Entscheidung der Bundesregierung die hat
ja ohne uns getroffen was bedeutet das
für das
Haushaltsverfahren es ist in der Tat so
dass der Bundeshaushalt 2024 ja Ausgaben
vorsieht die auch aus dem
aus diesem Fond aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond mit finanziert
werden sollen diese Ausgaben können
jetzt nicht mehr aus dem KTF finanziert
werden der Bundesfinanzminister hat
richtigerweise eine sofortige
ausgabensperre verhängt also alle die
Projekte die ja zum Teil auch zugesagt
worden sind die rechtsverbind
eingegangen worden sind durch die
Bundesregierung müssen jetzt aus dem
laufenden et finanziert werden der
laufende et sieht dafür die Ausgaben
nicht vor aber die Ausgaben müssen
vorgelegt werden das heißt also die
Bundesregierung muss im Grunde genommen
jetzt das Haushaltsverfahren neu
beginnen und muss die Zusagen die sie
gegeben hat zu Lasten des KTF machen im
Wege von entweder korrigierten zusagen
oder ausfinanzierten Zusagen durch den
regulären Bundeshaushalt dafür gibt es
im Augenblick keine Grundlage dafür
Berat berät jetzt der Haushaltsausschuss
auf dem auf der Basis eines nicht mehr
gültigen Haushaltsplanes so die
Bundesregierung will da offensichtlich
mit dem Kopf durch die Wand das werden
wir uns genau anschauen was sie dann da
vorhat aber wenn wir anstelle der
Bundesregierung wären dann würden wir
das Haushaltsverfahren jetzt stoppen und
einen neuen Haushaltsplan aufsetzen man
kann auch ins nachfolgende Jahr gehen
sind die ersten Wochen und Monate unter
vorläufiger Haushaltsführung dann kann
man nur die Ausgaben machen die im
laufenden Haushalt des Vorjahres bereits
monatsweise eingegangen sind aber die
Bundesregierung scheint einen anderen
Weg zu gehen den werden wir uns genau
anschauen wie schnell kann das praktisch
gehen und wie lange vorläufig haush also
man kann Haushalte innerhalb von wenigen
Wochen aufstellen aber wenn es
kompliziert wird dauert ein paar Monate
die Frage die kann ich ihn nicht
beantworten das muss die Bundesregierung
beantworten vielleicht das erstes mal
darauf hinweisen es gilt der Grundsatz
der Haushalt Klarheit und Wahrheit so
nachdem muss entschieden werden und
jetzt ist ein 60 Milliarden Euro Loch
entstanden
und da soll eine bereinigungsitzung
morgen stattfinden die dann in der
nächsten Woche im Bundestag
verabschiedet darüber entscheiden soll
wie diese Haushalte der nächsten Jahre
ausschauen ohne 60 Milliarden dass das
nicht seriös funktionieren kann ist doch
ganz offensichtlich man muss ja nicht
nur für den Haushalt 24 sondern auch für
die mittelfristige Finanzplanung sorgen
und dafür Klarheit schaffen wo werden
diese 60 Milliarden eben nicht
eingesetzt werden können das ist doch
das was man am mindestens erwarten kann
von einer Bundesregierung die so ein
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil bekommen hat
und deswegen ein Verschieben dieser
Haushaltssystematik und Entscheidungen
heißt doch nicht dass es gar nicht mehr
kommt wir haben doch noch mehrere Wochen
bis zum Ende dieses Jahres von daher
besteht nach wie vor die Möglichkeit
auch mit einem Verschieben der
Haushaltssitzung in diesem Jahr zu einem
Abschluss des Haushaltsverfahrens zu
kommen und wenn das nicht ginge wäre es
auch im nächsten Jahr noch möglich aber
erstmal muss Haushalt Klarheit und
Wahrheit geschaffen werden alles andere
ist wieder vermurgst und bietet wieder
entsprechende Angriffspunkte und wenn es
zu einem verfassungswiedrigen Haushalt
kommt werden wir das auch wieder
öffentlich deutlich anbrangen vielen
Dank fürs kommenel
dank ja soweit Alexander Dobrind und
Friedrich märz mit ihrer Beurteilung des
Urteils dass da heute aus karlsruh